what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today I wanted to try something a little
bit different just to switch things up
and add a little variety to the channel
because as we know variety is the pepper
of life or something like that anyway
the inspiration for this video is really
twofold the first of which is a comic
that's been published by Marvel on and
off ever since the late 1970s called
what if for those of you guys who don't
know what F was a series where the
writers would try to imagine an
alternate timeline of events than what
had actually happened in the main Marvel
Universe and basically tell out of
continuity stories based on those
hypothetical situations for example
there was an issue that asked the
question what if spider-man had saved
when Stacey when she was John from a
bridge by Norman Osborn they don't
really use that many words but that's
more or less the gist of the story and
there was another one that asked the
question what if Wolverine had killed
the Hulk during their first battle and
basically the writers of these issues
simply told a story based on this
alternate hypothetical set of facts the
other motivation behind this is the fact
that you guys keep asking me to make
videos like this so I'm gonna make a
video I'm going to give us a shot we're
going to see what happens so because
Marvel isn't really publishing what if
comics really anymore I think the last
day did was infinity and they're
certainly not doing them an all-new
all-different marvel and because of the
fact that seeing a Marvel vs. DC
crossover really or Amaro and DC
crossover in the modern day is really
Sony's just kind of left to the left of
the birds I figured why not fill the
void here on my channel and give this a
shot so with that in mind we're going to
get a little experimental today and
we're going to ask the question what if
the Incredible Hulk was given a red
lantern rate so in order to tell the
story properly we have to know exactly
what it is that we're dealing with so in
case anyone watching this is not aware
of what the Red Lantern rings are or how
they work we'll start with an
explanation of their history as well as
the powers and abilities they bestow
upon their wearers so back when Geoff
Johns was writing his character-defining
run on the Green Lantern which we cover
here every Sunday one of the biggest
things he did was create an entire
emotional spectrum of different lanterns
each one having a different color and
each color representing a different
emotion along the spectrum prior to this
we had only ever seen green lanterns and
comics but John's expanded the idea of
the Lantern Corps and made the green
lanterns just one of many aspects of a
much larger picture while the green
lanterns derived
from willpower there are other Lantern
cores that get their powers from other
emotions including the Red Lanterns who
rely on the emotion of rage for their
strength now that brings us to the Red
Lantern power ring the source of power
for all red lanterns the red rings
themselves and the red lanterns central
power battery were created by Atrocitus
out of his rage and desire for revenge
on the guardians of the universe who he
blamed for the slaughter of almost every
person in his home sector drawing on the
central power battery the Red Lantern
race and view those who wear them with a
variety of powers and abilities but also
causes them to undergo a dramatic
transformation when the Red Lantern puts
on a ring the ring effectively replaces
their heart so that they can no longer
feel any emotion other than rage and
their singularly motivated to exact
revenge and wreak as much destruction as
possible the ring also transforms the
blood of its wearer into basically a
liquefied rage plasma that a lantern can
then regurgitate and the blood of these
red lanterns regurgitate is both
incendiary and extremely corrosive now
red lanterns are also able to fire the
rage-filled plasma as an energy blast
with destructive capabilities the extent
of which is directly related to the
level of Rage of the particular person
who's spewing this and their power
now other abilities offered by the Red
Lantern rings include the ability to
create light constructs out of red light
the durability of which depends on the
level of rage of the lantern creating
them as well as flight and the creation
of force fields that both shield the
lantern from harm as well as sustain
their physical requirements as a form of
life support and so now that we've
covered what a Red Lantern ring does we
next turn our attention to what the
Incredible Hulk powered by wet lantern
ring would be capable of and to do that
we first have to run over what the Hulk
can do without the ring so as most
anyone with any degree of familiarity
with the Incredible Hulk knows the
primary characteristic of the Hulk is
incredible strength which increases as
he gets angrier and has no known upper
limit this strength is complemented by
insane durability and a ridiculously
fast regenerative healing factor even in
his base form the Hulk is one of the
most powerful earthbound characters in
the Marvel Universe but if we add the
Red Lantern rein to the equation he
becomes a universal thread the likes of
which would draw the attention of the
entire gamut of marvel's heroes now the
key factor to consider is the effect
that rage or anger is going to have
a Hulk possessing the Red Lantern ring
as we said earlier the Red Lantern ring
is going to force Hulk into a physical
transformation where his heart and blood
are replaced by pure rage to the point
that anger is the only emotion he will
be able to feel he will be singularly
focused on expelling that rage in the
form of violence and getting revenge on
all those who have wronged him in the
past it's important to remember here
that as the Hawks rage level increases
so does his strength so what's going to
happen is essentially that the power of
the Ring will cause the Hulk to become
angrier than ever before which in turn
will cause him to become stronger than
ever before when you add in other
abilities granted by the Ring what we
would be dealing with here would
essentially be an invincible monster
that can fly create force fields and she
pure unadulterated energy out of his
hands and vomit from his mouth so just
think about that for a second the whole
flying over a city vomiting fire down
upon the people below that's a literally
dissipation that we're going to be
dealing with here so now that we have an
understanding of what's going on we face
the question of how this story would
play out if it were to ever actually
come to fruition specifically how would
the Hulk come into possession of the
ring what would he do once he got it and
how would he be stopped if at all well
of course the story would have to start
with some sort of crossover of the
Marvel and DC universes so I think a
good starting point here would be that
we have a Red Lantern ring that's
recovered by shield obviously no one in
shield knows what the ring is but like
all Lantern rings it immediately seeks
out a worthy host arriving in front of
Bruce Banner making the declaration you
have great rage in your heart you belong
to the Red Lanterns
after which Banner immediately begins
undergoing the change associated with
the Red Lantern Corps of course as he
gets angry his transformation into the
Hulk begins as well in a matter of
moments we have our complete
transformation as the Hulk is wearing
the ring vomiting his rage blood all
over the laboratory setting things on
fire and setting off all sorts of alarms
this of course brings a multitude of
shield agents down on Hulk who he
dispenses with easily now of course Tony
Stark Reed Richards and hate McCoy all
over hear the commotion as well because
they're in this base of operations or
what-have-you but after seeing the Hulk
destroy the shield agents they think
better of engaging him directly noting
to the last time he appeared to be this
angry it took an effort of the entire
Marvel
to stop him so they formulate a plan to
bring the Avengers the Fantastic Four
and the x-men together as quickly as
possible to take on this new threat in
the meantime the Hulk it's just raging
throughout the city probably New York
since this is Marvel Comics after all
shrugging off an enormous assault from
the US military unfazed by gunfire tanks
air strikes and anything else they can
throw at him I mean this is absolute
pandemonium like like even from the
civilian standpoint it's just absolutely
panic like old miss Jenkins been going
to the same church every day for like
the last 50 years has taken her
groceries home looks up in absolute
horror and she's like Oh Lord Jesus it's
just freaking out you know this nice
little black woman freaking out
absolutely losing her mind now of course
this brings in the heroes of course the
Fantastic Four the x-men and The
Avengers pretty much every hero in the
Marvel Universe comes together to try
and take down the Hulk so we get some
pretty epic battle sequences here as all
of these heroes unleash their full
offensive capabilities on the Red
Lantern Hulk but something we have to
keep in mind here is that we've seen
before how powerful and unstoppable the
Hulk can be when he's angry during the
World War Hulk storyline when the entire
Marvel Universe basically United to stop
the world breaker Hulk that version of
the Hulk was powerful enough to take out
all those who stood against him
including Doctor Strange channeling the
energy of a demon Iron Man in the
Hulkbuster armor the entire x-men team
Ghost Rider and the century both of whom
he battled to a draw and while that
version of Hope was incredibly angry due
to the fact that he'd been unwittingly
sent to the planets a car or he
eventually became ruler fell in love was
in the midst of starting a family when
the planet was blown up the level of
anger would pale in comparison to the
Red Lantern Hulk world Waker Hulk was
able to feel things other than anger he
exercised restraint he could have killed
the x-men during his battle with them
but he didn't because he didn't blame
them for the tragedy that he'd suffered
Red Lantern Hulk would not be so
discerning he would be motivated by pure
unadulterated rage and would seek out to
destroy everything and everyone in his
path
so as the battle rages on it becomes
clear that the heroes are going to fail
civilians are dying soldiers are dying
even heroes are dying on the ground we
cut to an exchange between like some
commanding officer of the US military
and Captain America the officer informs
cap that the word has come
down from the president that drastic
measures are going to be taken and a
massive bomb possibly even nuclear will
be dropped on New York to stop the
rampaging Hulk before he moves on to
other cities cap grab the officers radio
and Poor's the powers that be to
reconsider citing the fact that not only
is Hulk likely to survive the blast but
innocent lives will be lost
cap is told that the risks have been
considered and the president has decided
that the hope represents the largest
threat to US national security and all
available means will be taken to
neutralize them so most of those heroes
that have survived turn their attention
to trying to evacuate the area before
the bombs dropped while some of the most
powerful heroes attempt to carry on
their battle with the Hulk eventually
the plane carrying the bomb has seen
overhead the hatch opens and the bomb is
deployed as the heroes on the ground
look up in horror they're shocked to see
that the bomb is caught in midair by an
enormous green hand yes
suddenly there appears in the sky over
New York the entirety of the Green
Lantern and Blue Lantern course the blue
lanterns powered by the emotion of hope
use their rings to negate the rage of
the Hulk while the Green Lantern Corps -
Hal Jordan who's transporting the bomb
to the ocean or something like that or
all constructing a cell of green light
constructs to entrap the Hulk because
he's so filled with rage and so powerful
the Hulk initially resists the blue
lanterns efforts and smashes through the
cell created by the Green Lantern's but
to combine forces of the entire Blue
Lantern Corps proves to be too much and
the Hulk is finally subdued now
following this battle we see Bruce
Banner in a shield infirmary receiving
treatment from ibly lanterns to cure him
of the effects of the Red Lantern drink
while Hal Jordan talks with Captain
America Tony Stark Reed Richards of hey
McCoy how explains that in an attempt to
expand the Red Lantern Corps Atrocitus
had managed to find a small hole in the
barrier between the two universes but
big enough to send a Red Lantern ring
through once the ring found its way into
the Marvel Universe it shows the person
with the greatest capacity for rage
which it deemed to be the Hulk
once the Green Lantern's learned of
Atrocitus is planned they enlisted the
help of the blue lanterns and together
found a way to enlarge the rift between
the universes enough that they can all
pass through as they knew the universe
would not have
the knowledge or the ability to deal
with a red lantern and so after banners
been healed
Kyle Jordan takes the Red Lantern ring
back with him to the DC Universe to be
destroyed and we end with stark and cap
checking on Bruce Tanner when they ask
if he's okay of course he assures them
that he just needs to rest and when they
leave him in a hospital room to get some
much-needed sleep we zoom in on his face
with the last panel and we see a flicker
of red light appear in his eye before it
quickly returns to normal but what that
being said guys that is my little story
of how I think Red Lantern Incredible
Hulk Webb here and be defeated in the
Marvel Universe I am curious if you guys
enjoy something like this if you guys
think something like this was kind of
cool I hope it is I think it's pretty
fun I think it's pretty interesting it's
a really really cool little set of
events but ah without being said guys
we're going to bring this video to an
end if you are new here to come and
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the wild port
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you
guys later please
[Music]